the two questions I reckon
I get asked the most are
what are my favourite cleaning appliances
and do I have a Kärcher discount code
so I'm gonna show you 4 tools I can't live without
and I don't exactly have a code
but I do have a really good PSA
cause Kärcher’s Black Friday sale is on now
and you can score up to 50% off some of my favourites
okay so coming in at No. 1
and I feel like everybody knows this
but it's my Kärcher Steam Cleaner
it comes with so many different attachments
so you can basically tackle any area
and it kills up to 99.99% of bacteria just using steam
coming in at No. 2 is my Hard Floor Cleaner or as I prefer to call her
the Sweepy Moppy Thingy
I use it every single day
it sweeps and mops at the same time
and the way that it just glides across the
floor is so effortless and satisfying
spot No. 3 was hotly contested
but if I have to choose it's gotta be the Water Blaster
if you watch my CleanToks you'll see I use this thing all the time
and I'm always genuinely surprised at how much I love it
and if my husband had a vote
he would definitely pop the Kärcher Wet & Dry vacuum in here
cause it's just fantastic for renovations
but he doesn't have a vote
so I'm picking the Window Vac system
because it's just perfect for windows
mirrors shower glass and condensation
if you live in an older home like me
a couple of my personal life philosophies are
never buy anything at full price
and if you have the right tool for the job
the job is easier
if you wanna make cleaning easier for
yourself or a loved one
check out the sale cause the tools are great
and the savings are impressive
and if you're keen to get clean by Christmas
I'll pop a link where you'd expect to find it